- [Reporter] Missile launchers in Belarus,
military tents in Crimea, and additional
artillery units in western Russia.
Images taken in early February
show how Moscow continued to deploy
its armed forces to surround Ukraine.
After several months of military buildup,
this map shows where Russian resources
were stationed to the north,
south, and east of the country,
all despite diplomatic efforts from the US
and NATO to de-escalate tensions.
Moscow has repeatedly denied
planning to attack Ukraine,
but armed forces experts in
the US have been skeptical.
- This is not a buildup for an exercise.
This is a buildup for military use.
- [Reporter] The type
of equipment deployed,
and the presence of fighter aircraft,
usually the last units to
arrive prior to combat,
indicated that the Russian
army was in position
for a potential attack,
according to analysts.
- Combination of artillery,
mortar rifle infantry,
armor, logistical support.
- [Reporter] Russia's movements have been
particularly visible in
the west of the country,
Belarus, and Crimea, suggesting
that the army would have
the capability to stage attacks
from multiple locations.
Nearly a year ago, Moscow was already
building up troops and
equipment in Crimea,
an area in the south of Ukraine
which it annexed in 2014.
In April, it positioned military forces
in the area for an exercise,
many of whom never left.
Satellite imagery captured five Russian
military training areas in the region.
It showed the camps expanded
further in recent weeks.
This is one of them, Novoozerne,
in September last year,
and again in December.
In these images, we can see equipment
such as trucks lined up.
And just over a month later,
the camp seen in this image
expanded with a new section of tents.
- What you're seeing in the image suggests
that personnel have either
arrived, or are about to arrive,
so it suggests a more advanced level
of preparations in the Russian military.
- [Reporter] That's Michael Kofman,
a specialist on the Russian military
at the research organization CNA Corp.
Kofman said evidence of
troops arriving at camps
could also be seen in these images
from western Russia in late January.
He said the appearance
of dark spots indicate
that snow is melting on the tents
because heaters are being
used inside of them.
In early February, military analysts
watching Russian movements reported
that the camp had started to empty out
to leave for positions
closer to Ukraine's border.
Moscow says it's moved
the equipment and troops
in the region for training drills
because it feels threatened
by NATO and the West.
Russian president Vladimir Putin accused
the Western military alliance of fueling
anti-Russian sentiment on its borders,
as Ukraine sought membership of the bloc.
But stationing units for
exercise in winter weather
is unusual, according to Phillip Karber,
a former Pentagon official who's currently
the president of a policy
research organization.
- Everything's more lethal,
everything's more terrible.
You know, you're out
there in subzero weather,
with the fact that they're
bringing this massive stuff
in very uncomfortable conditions of winter
is also a very unusual sign.
- [Reporter] Karber, who's
traveled several times
to the front lines in Ukraine in the past,
said the images showed
there was more equipment
stationed in western Russia than what's
normally been observed
for routine testing.
- When you're going into combat,
you're carrying at least,
for that unit, at least
three days' worth of
ammunition for full out combat.
That takes a lot of trucks,
and all of a sudden,
in these photographs,
the trucks are there.
- [Reporter] The buildup
of weapons has also
been photographed in other regions
outside of Russia's borders.
Military analysts said that suggests
if an attack were to take place,
it could be multi-directional,
meaning the offensive could happen
from different locations simultaneously,
potentially close to some
of Ukraine's major cities.
- It's very likely that in the event
of a Russian military operation,
that there would be an
attack along multiple axes,
to Kiev from Belarus,
into northeastern Ukraine
from western military districts,
and from the very south in Crimea.
- [Reporter] These images
show stocks of Russian
SS26 Iskander missiles in Belarus,
according to Karber and Kofman.
They have a range of
around 400 kilometers,
and can be used with nuclear warheads.
Russian fighter jets were also pictured
in Belarus ahead of military drills.
Military experts point out that air forces
are normally the last to arrive in an area
before military action
to support ground troops.
But even if movements on
the ground have increased,
analysts in the US and
other Western countries
say they don't know if Putin made
a final decision to attack.
Moscow has an array of options,
including capturing a limited area,
or using its current presence to negotiate
and attain more influence in
political power in Ukraine.
Putin demands guarantees that NATO
won't give membership to Ukraine,
and that the alliance
reduces its activities
in countries close to Russia,
but it's a risky calculus,
as Ukraine and Western countries
also increase their firepower
in preparation for a potential crisis.
- Are there costs associated with
mobilization and all that
stuff, without using it?
Absolutely, but it would be the cheapest,
if he could get us and Ukraine to concede,
that's the cheapest victory he ever had.